um you you clearly are a big believer
then in the China story you've got a big
commitment there what is the potential
for Disney Shanghai as we look at China
as an economy that just continues to
grow well I'm a big believer in China
for Disney one of the things that we've
seen which is you know in just an
incredible and in terms of its
opportunity is the huge growth of movie
screens in China to the point where
China is now the number two movie market
in the world and if this growth
continues in the next five years it will
be the number one movie market in the
world clearly Disney films and Marvel
films and probably Star Wars films will
not only be welcome in the market but
will be loved in the market we've
certainly seen that today with Disney
and Pixar and and Marvel and so there's
clearly opportunity there and with a
connection that people make to those
stories and those characters obviously a
company like ours is set up to leverage
that connection from those stories in
other businesses we talked about
consumer product but clearly a theme
park business is one way to leverage the
interest in those stories and those
characters and that's what you'll see in
Shanghai Disneyland we also know that a
theme park is an immersive experience a
high quality and experience and
experience that Disney fans really
connect with and that can be a huge
boost to the strength of a brand in a
market you can look at Japan and you
know immediately see the impact of tokyo
disneyland on perception of the disney
brand and the disney business in japan
as the for instance so we view Shanghai
Disneyland is not only being you know
fantastic initiative unto itself but we
also see it as potentially a huge brand
anchor a huge booster rocket for our
brand in that market